the universally awful experience of
putting together IKEA furniture has led
some scientists to wonder can robots
just do this for us it turns out a task
like this is incredibly difficult for
robots as well but for different reasons
recent advances in robotics and
artificial intelligence have produced
BOTS that can do everything and driving
cards by themselves to beating world
champion go players but that doesn't
mean they can manipulate objects with
precision on their own that's because
the ability to deftly move and rotate
objects requires juggling many complex
interactions at once humans do this
every day but for robots locating
objects in space both visually and by
touch planning out complex motions
controlling force and coordinating
multiple arms at once is a tremendous
challenge researchers wanted to see if
they could meet that challenge by
building a robot from commonly available
parts the robot was made of
off-the-shelf hardware industrial robot
arms parallel grippers for sensors and a
3d camera to monitor its environment
first the robots scanned the room with a
3d camera to get to know its
surroundings and figure out where all
those annoying tiny parts work then
using open-source software the robot
planned out its each and every move this
was actually the most time-consuming
part of the process finally the chair
has been assembled and a record-breaking
time of 8 minutes and 55 seconds
including programming time the whole
process took just over 20 minutes pretty
impressive right we challenged people
here at science to build the same kind
of IKEA chair in the same amount of time
the skills came easy the chair not so
much our human contestants beat the
robots time but just barely
the humans didn't have any issue
coordinating or plan
usually doing everything all at once the
real challenge is using those tiny hex
wrenches using artificial intelligence
robots in the future could autonomously
assemble furniture by simply reading the
manual or even just analyzing an image
of a completed chair until then maybe
get a friend or a bot to help you out
with that chair
[Music]